foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's uh it's that time of year and
uh wanted to do something seasonal
except I I didn't uh I didn't have a
notion that really seemed to fit it too
well but then I looked over the stuff
that I've been commissioned to review
and something jumped out of me like oh
that's seasonally appropriate and I was
commissioned to review that entire
season of Television so that
that probably deserves a little bit more
dissection than I sometimes end up doing
with the commission reviews which are
usually over on the break room of Geeks
you know unscripted ramblings here
there's enough to talk about that it
deserves a little bit more time so I
guess I'll actually take the opportunity
to plug the patreon here at the front
end because much more directly than is
even standard this video is indeed
sponsored by my patreon and that is what
has caused all of this to come about
link down in the description if you wish
to support me there I couldn't do it
without that help so let's talk about
American Horror Story now this is a show
that I have seen well parts of it I
watched the first five seasons of
American Horror Story and my opinions of
it are kind of mixed and I think like
even like fans of the show it's a little
bit variable from season to season
I saw Murder House Asylum coven freak
Show and hotel now the show has
continued on since then and is actually
still on I do believe
um I tried to get back into it basically
like I just had enough things go on in
my life that I kind of fell off it as it
was airing tried to go back to it I just
wasn't getting into the headspace as
well and I kind of left it at that but
here's something that I find interesting
when talking about American Horror Story
if you ask someone who has seen multiple
Seasons whether they've seen all of them
or only a chunk of them like I have if
you ask them what is their favorite
season of the show that often says more
about their taste than it does about the
show itself so for instance I know a
number of people who feel that murder
house the first one is the best those
are also people who gravitate towards
ghost and haunted house stories just as
a general preference when it comes to
horror her my favorite of the ones I've
seen is Asylum because if you're going
to try and genuinely unnerve me messing
with my perception of reality yeah that
hits me a lot harder than ghosts or
Monsters does that's a that's a good way
to genuinely unsettle me and I also tend
to think that messing with perceptions
is a good way to sort of get an audience
to roll with some of the more out there
stuff any given of Any Given season of
the show has a tendency to do
but whatever your preference for horror
there's probably something in one of
these Seasons that is going to cater to
it in a slightly overblown arguably at
times a little bit can't be way that is
just the overall tone of the thing but
in terms of just the specifics there's
probably something here for you
so it's with some frustration that my
commission was for coven which of the
seasons that I have seen is the one I
liked the least I'm not even sure it's
the weakest that might have been Hotel
although Hotel was more uneven than we
could cross the board but coven I didn't
really like uh when I saw it initially
now I understand part of why at least I
suspect part of why I may have been
commissioned for this particular season
is that this is the most popular season
of the show definitely going by ratings
while it doesn't have the highest
numbers for the initial Premiere episode
it does hold the highest ratings for the
finale of any season and the highest
average viewers for the season as a
whole this is at least by the Numbers
the most popular and successful season
of American Horror Story and re-watching
it eyes
still don't really like it
very much
at all
but now we've got a platform and I can
talk and dissect uh some of the reasons
why I suppose the first thing I should
clarify if there's one thing that I do
not take issue with and actually this is
true of all the seasons of the show that
I have seen the issue is not the actors
it's not the performances actually a lot
of these performers are really good and
this season in particular introduces a
number of people who would make later
appearances and they're great additions
to the cast Kathy Bates being one Angela
Bassett being another also Gabourey
Sidibe is Queenie these are good strong
additions from good Actors and The
Returning actors who had been in other
Seasons prior like Jessica Lang like
Lily Rob like Sarah Paulson Dennis
O'Hare they all do good work with the
characters that they're given everyone
is pretty well suited for what they have
been asked to do Emma Roberts is a great
fit for the character she's playing
Jamie Brewer is absolutely really
wonderful she was one of the highlights
of the first season for me Tyson Farmiga
Danny Houston like all good there's one
there's one exception but it's not that
the performance is bad it's that it's
just a severe under use of the actor but
you know what um I'll I'll get back to
that let's do a little bit of an
overview for anyone who maybe hasn't
seen the season of show or it's been
long enough that they need a refresher
coven is set in New Orleans which is a
pretty good place to set anything that
is witchcraft or Magic based the area
has a very strong history with that kind
of stuff particularly when it comes to
various Voodoo practices although that
doesn't ultimately end up being a good
thing in the hands of this show but
again I'll come back to that but there's
some really interesting real life
history that is available and made use
of so that's the setting we deal with a
coven of witches initially started by
survivors of Salem Massachusetts stick a
pin in that as well I'm also going to
have thoughts on that but it deals with
this school that is meant to find young
women with magical abilities who are
young burgeoning witches and basically
serve as Charles Xavier's home for
gifted youngsters
um for witches
um but the coven is not in great shape
part of that has to do with its leader
that's Fiona played by Jessica Lang who
is so good like she's she's every season
of this show that she's in she's great
but she's real good here Fiona is what
is known as the Supreme that is a witch
who has shown the most Talent unable to
do this very specific combination of
abilities that proves that she is the
center of the power but she's been a
terrible Supreme she has neglected her
Duty she is not really properly run the
coven or the school that is being
handled by her daughter played by Sarah
Paulson so things are just not great but
we have a number of young women being
brought in all of whom have a special
specific ability that they have
manifested now it'll turn out later on
that they can manifest multiple things
although whether that's permanent or
just because of some of the other stuff
going on isn't super clear but what we
have initially is again very x-men-like
because we have Nan who is psychic and
has a certain amount of mind reading
abilities there's Madison Montgomery
who's telekinetic there's Zoe who is
kind of termed a black widow basically
if she has sex with someone it will kill
that other person and then there's
Queenie who is a quote unquote living
voodoo doll basically if she is focusing
her power and concentrating anything
that happens to her body will be
inflicted upon somebody else so that's
who we start with as we get a sense of
how they feel about each other how well
they're getting along the state of the
coven but
um and quite a few other things are
going to end up coming into play and I'm
not going to do a beat for beat plot
breakdown but basically as it progresses
other characters get factored into
proceedings and the main thrust of it is
largely around who is going to be the
next Supreme because the reason Fiona is
around again is because she is starting
to well on a honestly she's got cancer
and she's just aging and dying but from
her perspective if that's happening to
her it means a new supreme is rising and
that's why she is fading so one of these
girls in theory is going to be the next
Supreme
which brings me to the first kind of
major hiccup of this which is Episode by
episode a lot of what is being dealt
with in the immediate narrative has
little to nothing to do with who may or
may not be the next Supreme that is an
idea that is continuously referenced and
brought up but not a lot of actual
narrative weight is given to it and
exactly how much many of these
characters even really care about it
even though they're talking about it
doesn't it doesn't feel like it's
actually super committed to that idea
but it is going to be the through line
and it's ultimately gonna be what the
whole thing is building towards in the
note it's going to end on but it really
does feel like just an excuse for
connective tissue because they wanted
there to be an overall point but it just
never feels like a particularly strong
issue for basically anybody other than
Fiona and even Fiona gets deeply
distracted with how she ends up tying in
some of the other characters we get
introduced to now this is actually a
good place for me to pause and segue
into some of the real life figures
referenced or who appear in this series
and that will also allow me to take some
of the pins out some of the stuff that I
said I would deal with later so in terms
of historical figures specific to New
Orleans there are three major ones who
basically appear and have significance
to the story a particular narrative
weight and an actual presence so that is
Delphine lalaurie who was a real life
horrible horrible person she lived there
at a time when slavery was still a thing
and she tortured and seemed to be very
happy to be absolutely atrocious to the
slaves that she had ownership over there
is Marie Laveau who is a real life
historical figure sometimes referred to
as the voodoo queen of New Orleans and
there's also the ax man a real life turn
of the century Ax Murderer who terrorize
New Orleans for a time and was
self-professed to have a love of jazz
now of these characters I have basically
no real criticism about how the ax man
is handled because that is a killer who
was never actually caught we don't know
who it was so basically you pretty much
have free reign to do what you want with
him as long as you get the primary
details of what he was about down which
this seemed to for the most part at
least in the broad Strokes so beyond
that yeah you can kind of go nuts so I
actually am not going to have much issue
with him but that is a real life figure
so he needed to be mentioned here with
delphian lalaurie who's played by
um Kathy Bates and who is really good in
the part the first thing is that they
definitely mess with some of the
specifics about her and generally when
you're talking about someone who
ended other people's lives there are
questions to be had of is that
disrespectful to the memories of people
she killed to be as loose with how she
is portrayed here
I'm not going to say there isn't a
conversation to be had there I'm not
excessively gonna lean on that though
because I would say that for the most
part she is made to appear even worse
than she was in reality and they also
give a certain amount of catharsis to
what happens to her here that is not
reflective of reality but it's certainly
more narratively satisfying so while I
think there's still a conversation to be
had about how appropriate that is or
isn't
um given that in no way is it softening
or lessening her monstrosity I'm
personally not thrown off by it but
again I could understand arguments that
would take more issue with it Marie
Laveau is a little bit weird because she
is again a real life figure but we see
very little of her
in the time when she lived because she
played by Angela Bassett again excellent
in the part but she is uh presented as
someone who is Immortal and still alive
now so there actually is very little
actively depicted about her from the
times when she was alive and pretty much
all the characterization if you say it's
inconsistent with the historical figure
you can lay it on well she's been it's
not even like she's leaped forward in
time she's been continuously alive so
she's changed with time and like
that works as a Band-Aid for to avoid
that issue
um definitely when you are dealing with
someone like Marie Laveau it could have
gone a lot worse
um the way that they chose to do it and
the way that they opted to integrate
this character into the story
structurally just means that they get a
lot more leeway that doesn't feel like
they are twisting history I mean just
beyond the fact that she's now Immortal
in and of itself but while those are the
only historical figures who make
significant direct appearances in the
show
there are a number of real world things
that are still involved here that I do
have much more issue with
let's start with Salem at this point in
time I have a general issue with any uh
fictionalization of what happened at
Salem Massachusetts in The Witch Trials
there that involves the idea that there
were actual real witches there those
girls weren't even witches the real
witches were cunning and careful not to
be caught that fundamentally
misunderstands what happened in Salem
what happened in Salem
is a historical tragedy and a monstrous
piece of History
because there were no witches there
witches were used as an excuse
to steal land
and steal property
and clamped out on and ultimately murder
multiple people
to imply or even outright State as
something like this does that there were
actual witches there
is to basically say oh
no they were right to go on a Witch Hunt
they just got the wrong people no it's a
tragedy because none of it should have
been happening you put actual witches in
Salem and you imply that the hunt for
witches was in some way correct even if
you're going to take the kind of stance
that this does that which is our overly
persecuted that's not why Salem is a
tragedy that I do genuinely take issue
with and if anyone's gonna ask me I
don't have a super big problem with the
fact that Salem is a bit of a tourist
town around the witch trials and a bit
of a witch aesthetic like I'm not gonna
say that it's the most cool thing in the
world to be doing but like it's also a
small town that has almost nothing else
to its name and no other reason for
tourists to come around so like I get it
I get it but for fiction like this no
actually I've kind of got a big problem
with that and it makes it a little bit
worse by specifically invoking Tituba
now Tituba was was the servant of the
Reverend Paris in Salem who was one of
the first to confess to Witchcraft now
within the context of American Horror
Story coven Queenie is a descendant of
Tituba so they are pulling in her very
specifically and that is actually even a
little bit worse because while yes
tichiba did confess to Witchcraft there
is evidence including later
documentation from people who talked to
Tituba herself while she was still alive
that that confession was beaten out of
her so to say that someone who confessed
falsely to something after being beaten
was actually the thing they confessed to
that's
that's gross that's actually really
gross but then also like okay I'm
lumping this in with the quote unquote
real world stuff but we need to talk
about religion for a hot second and I
like I'm not trying to get into debate
of whether religions or real or beliefs
are you know factually accurate but like
the practices of certain religions are
real practices that go on and Voodoo
which comes up at multiple points in
this
is a real practice religion it's a very
um localized religion you know Haitian
Voodoo is a little bit different from
Cuban Voodoo is a little bit different
from exactly what tends to go on in New
Orleans and the way he's practiced is
there but there are certain
commonalities and it is an active live
living practiced form of religion so if
you're going to depict voodoo
you're gonna have to kind of be careful
about it especially if you're doing it
in the context of a bunch of other real
world history stuff you're bringing in
you kind of owe it a little bit of
respect especially when Again part of
your narrative is this idea that witches
are over persecuted you have an entire
side plot with witch Hunters dealing
with that concept so like if that's what
you're doing you kind of owe it to be
at least
vaguely accurate now
how accurate coven is or isn't to the
specifics of any of the practice of
voodoo I'm actually not in a position to
say I don't know Voodoo well enough and
I'm certainly not a practitioner of it
myself and never have been and even if I
tried to do the research there's a very
good chance I could get something wrong
however based off something I was able
to confirm
yeah I don't trust that they got any of
this right or respectful because the
thing that is not up for debate that
they screwed up is that there is a
character who appears and this is
someone that Marie Laveau supposedly cut
a deal with it's why she's Immortal now
this is a character who has identified
and named as Papa legba
your papa likepa papa legba is a real
life figure in Voodoo practices and the
voodoo religion the problem here is that
what is depicted on screen is visually
coded and very reminiscent of Baron
samity a completely different figure
from Voodoo religion
they basically took one Voodoo figure
and made made him look like a completely
different one but called him this one
that does not bode well for any of this
any of the voodoo stuff as being
anything other than an absolute disaster
because that that should be basic
if you're going to name a character in
your show after a real religious figure
but make them look like a completely
different one that just shows a level of
disrespect like all right I'm gonna make
a comparison that isn't ideal because
I'm gonna do a Christian comparison just
so people can like get the sense a
little bit better now Christianity it
doesn't map on quite as well because
there's only one actual deity in
Christianity or you know the Trinity if
you want to argue it but that's a whole
other thing my point is is that imagine
if you watched a movie or a show that
decided to depict as part of its
narrative
the last supper and crucifixion and
final days of Jesus Christ
and imagine that you had somebody whose
role in the story everything about how
he behaves says the actions he takes
it all like that's Judas that's Judas
Iscariot
and like he does all the things Judas
does all that he's known for in those
stories in that religion in those
beliefs
but he was called Pontius Pilate and not
like in a way that's like ooh we're
doing a Twist on it like no they just
they just called someone the completely
wrong name like that's not who that was
that would show a pretty high level of
disrespect
even if unintentional even if it's done
by accident it shows a level of
disrespect from not putting in any leg
work whatsoever to just call it who it
is if you want to use Baron samity call
it Baron samity why would you have
someone look like Baron samity and call
them Papa legba
that's just
callus at best that is deeply deeply
callous and that is a lack of respect to
an active practiced religion
unfortunately as much as that stuff
bought to me actually way more than it
did on my first time watching this some
years ago
um because I did do a full re-watch of
this thing while that bothered me a lot
more now all of the old stuff that I
remember bothering me does also still
bother me uh what does that include well
I mentioned uh for all the actors that I
praise there is one actor who if you
know American Horror Story you probably
would have noticed that he is
conspicuous by his absence in terms of
those who I named
this thing really does not utilize Evan
Peters very well at all Evan Peters has
been one of the highlights and joys of
this franchise he's kind of how I
discovered him as an actor and he has
always been good he's not even bad in
this where he plays Kyle who is
effectively a magically raised
Frankenstein kind of thing but it gives
him almost nothing to do following his
initial introduction and then death and
then Resurrection stick a pin in the
resurrections we're gonna come back to
those too he then just kind of mopes
around he barely says anything and like
Peter's is doing about as much as any
actor is going to be able to do with the
part but unfortunately after about the
halfway mark it's almost nothing there's
a little bit of stuff that like
definitely has some uh let's go with
some narrative weight it's also deeply
uncomfortable and I think there's
conversations to be had as whether or
not it was an appropriate storyline in
the first place but
um there is is definitely some stuff in
regards to Kyle and Kyle's mother that
like well there's a story there for sure
but once that's wrapped up he's just
kind of around I honestly kept
forgetting he existed until he would
show up and see him be like oh yeah
right and they like try and make him an
object of affection for both Zoe and
Madison but those two already hated each
other for other reasons so it's not like
that is stoking a division between them
they already didn't like each other it's
just such a waste of one of the best
recurring acting talents that this show
has and honestly as much as I said that
Kathy Bates is really good as Delphine
Lottery because Kathy Bates is just
really good in everything she's also
kind of Wasted by the time it's done
the initial introduction of Delphine
Lottery is again appropriately horrific
interesting when you realize that she
was basically cursed with immortality
initially buried underground and left
there for a long dang time and now alive
but very much you know out of place in
the world you know that at the time
Obama was President that's brought to
her attention and she really can't
handle any of this and it's pretty well
portrayed but the thing is Delphine as a
character kind of stops mattering after
a while once it gets established that
what Marie Laveau did to her to cursor
is not something that she would ever do
for Fiona to help Fiona counteract her
issues with cancer then delphine's just
kind of there and also has very little
to do and they try and like build up by
giving her additional flashback stuff
even late into the show but all it is is
reiterating all the stuff that we
already knew about her it's just more
specific instance says of how horrible
she was and all that had already been
established
she got introduced really well
but the story had no use for her by the
halfway mark and again she's just kind
of there
what a waste honestly I feel like this
is too many episodes it's 13 episodes
long and I'm kind of thinking back to
some of the criticism that I had to the
Marvel Netflix which is if you lost
three episodes on this and so it's not
reiterating stuff or stretching stuff
for as long or spinning its wheels or
literally recycling characters trying to
give you a shock value of their death
and then suddenly they're back which
that'll segue us right into the
resurrections because holy crap now what
I actually went through there are
there's a pretty high number of
characters who do in fact die and stay
dead Kyle's mom Nan Luke Joan Hank
actually the entire Council of witch
Hunters whole bunch of Jackass frat Bros
like just overall the thing is not
without a body count
however let's talk real quick about how
meaningless death is in this show and
yet they continue to bank on it like it
should matter every time they keep
killing these people over and over again
first of all we've already got two
functionally Immortal characters in this
in the form of Marie Laveau and Delphine
lalory there's already a question as to
how much does death matter because we've
established that immortality is a thing
but beyond that we then have the
character of Misty day who gets
introduced basically on the basis of
Resurrection is her entire skill set but
even Beyond her being around we have
multiple characters later on start to
show that they can also resurrect people
so let's go down the list of characters
who died quote unquote but didn't really
now the first big one is Kyle who dies
gets sewn back together and resurrected
we have the character of Myrtle snow
burned at the stake it later resurrected
Misty arguably comes back twice twice
once definitely for sure resurrected a
second time left for dead in a situation
we're supposed to think she's gonna die
but recovers from that Madison killed
and resurrected Spalding died not
resurrected but sticks around as a ghost
who's about as tangible and influential
as the character was when he was alive
similarly the ax man dies is technically
a ghost but he's around and he's
interacting with stuff and he's for all
intents and purposes he's alive again
random homeless guy that gets killed the
who Zoe resurrects and then after all
this the show has the audacity to kill
Zoe in the final episode bring her back
within the same episode and give us a
fake out death for Fiona and even though
that one's technically not a
resurrection like why why would anyone
place any value on any character's death
at that point even the ones who stay
dead you just numb to it by this point
because nearly all the main characters
have died and come back it just sucks
all the stakes out of the drama there's
no tension when somebody is either left
in a situation where they're probably
gonna die or just flat out killed you're
like okay are they gonna come back too
it's way overused and like even beyond
the idea if they establish one character
as the power of Resurrection again it's
done by so many people and or things
that where the character maybe does in
fact die but is functionally still
around like Spalding
death has no meaning in this season none
and then there's sort of just a general
overall issue I've had with most seasons
of American Horror Story that I've seen
which is that the rules are not very
well established and they feel very
loose it either feels like the writers
know what the rules are but they're not
going to let the audience in on enough
of them that we can keep up with what's
happening because things keep happening
that feel like shouldn't that break the
rules that were established before or it
feels like they're just making things up
as they go along I felt that about as I
said nearly every season I didn't really
feel that necessarily about freak Show
but that is one of the more uh grounded
and least Supernatural ones at least of
the seasons that I have seen and I would
actually even argue that it worked in
Asylum because again when you're dealing
with this idea of the perception of
reality and can you even trust your own
brain or can any of the characters trust
theirs doing things that appear to break
the rules feels like it goes with the
flow much more than being something it's
like wait how does this work again
that's something that I felt in murder
house where I felt like I was three
quarters of the way in still trying to
figure out how the rules of these ghosts
worked but in Coven it's that oh to the
third power at least where they'll
introduce rules about like everyone has
one gift and they start manifesting
multiple gifts I didn't know you could
do that neither did I until now but then
Kyle gets initially resurrected by two
people who don't have the gift of
resurrection and it's before we get to
the point of the story which established
that they're all developing new gifts so
like you can still do something that
isn't part of your gift if you have the
right spell these characters are
Immortal until we decide that they're
not this character died and will be
resurrected this character died but will
not be for
reasons and that more than anything is
kind of my big frustration with this it
really feels all over the place in that
it kind of shifts a lot of its focus
from episode to episodes and rewrites
the rules every time and then because it
keeps bring characters back from the
dead or like has Immortal characters who
don't die their characters who stick
around well past their utility I kind of
honestly feel that way about Myrtle snow
whose role in the story is most
impactful prior to her initial death
after her Resurrection she does a couple
of things but nothing that couldn't have
theoretically been done by other people
why did we actually bring her back I
mean they brought her back because it's
Francis Conroy and she's really good but
like for the story and I suppose that's
the thing I'm I'm a story person
more than anything whatever else is
going on whether it is a horror trying
to scare me a comedy trying to make me
laugh or whatever it may be
I'm a story person first I want the
story to be a good narrative wonderful
characters funny moments scary moments
all these things are icing I expect the
foundation I expect the cake to be the
story and as you can make the prettiest
icing in the world if the cake has
fallen apart underneath it then I'm
gonna have a problem and that is
honestly part of why I have not tried to
get back into American Horror Story it
is very into feel and aesthetic and just
a general sense of the kind of horror
it's going for that season
and it's more interested in evoking that
continuously and however it feels like
doing it than it is in actually
structuring the narrative in a way that
doesn't kind of drive me up the wall
again some Seasons worked better for me
than others but the priority for the
showrunner seems to be well wherever
story Falls it's not in the top five
concerns of how they handle what they do
any given season and that feels
especially egregious in Coven at least
it does to me and then there's a
bunch of smaller stuff positive and
negative I appreciate that they never
had delfine Lottery like Get over or
start to really come back from her
fundamentally racist views this is not
someone who ever should have been
redeemed and they didn't even as she
softens slightly in certain ways they
make it clear multiple times over like
oh no no this does not make anything
about her okay good because if you come
for a Redemption Arc that would have
been awful 100 years from now and they
dig me up again
the natural order will be restored I
also appreciate the fact that despite
Madison being a very sexualized
character it's always made clear that
she is doing that by choice and the one
time when it is done against her will
that is made incredibly clear that she
in no way brought this on herself and
did not deserve it as I said lots of
good lots of strong performances from
most of the core cast but then there's
also some things that I'm not going to
dwell on but there's some things that
are just frankly gross there's the
storyline with Kyle and his mom which is
gross and it kind of feels gross for the
sake of being gross there's a moment
with Queenie and this Minotaur which I
don't have the time to explain what the
deal with the Minotaur is but that it
felt really gross where that went too
because it kind of implies that the
assault she suffered was something that
she brought on herself willingly and
don't you want to love me that's gross
and actually kind of made worse because
of what I praised about with Madison
where the conventional attractive white
girl is afforded some degree of dignity
whereas it's not given to Queenie but
again these are the kinds of things this
show just does and are kind of reasons
why I I haven't tried re-engaging with
it
if there was ever a point where I was
more willing to overlook these sorts of
things and not have it drag the entire
experience down for me they're long past
but again I feel like it's important for
me to point out even when I watched this
initially when this sort of stuff didn't
bother me nearly as much as it does now
I still didn't like this season it's
just kind of a mess with ever-changing
rules characters who die and come back
all the time to the point that I can't
get a handle on what the stakes of any
of this is it's it's just
by the end
kind of a model
there's some good strengths most of them
are strengths that the show has always
had it has a strong visual presentation
it's got very good actors the vast
majority of whom are in roles that
really suit them really well but the
story
the story is messy in a lot of places
and kind of uncomfortable in ways that
aren't fun in others and that's my
friends is coven next year around this
time I'll try and find something to talk
more positively about I did honestly go
into this re-watch hoping that I could
take the perspective of okay I know this
didn't work for me the first time maybe
I can you know go into it looking more
for the stuff that you know maybe I
forgot that worked and maybe I'll find a
bigger appreciation for it but that that
that didn't
that didn't really pan out I'll try to
find something more positive to go with
the season uh next year what are your
thoughts on American Horror Story
overall what are your thoughts on Coven
in particular
I have no doubt it's many people's
favorite and they're probably all mad at
me but whatever your thoughts are you
can disagree with me just please don't
call me names put something down in the
comments and let's talk about it
patreon's what pays the bills that is
how I was commissioned to take a look at
this and any amount you can help me with
there is a immense assistance is what
enables me to do this as my living but
even if you can't like share subscribe
also help what I really want you to
remember is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are magical
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
fulla Tarak the theme that goes joint in
the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
imudelki leotha Boyd toy lowly Becky
Sparks for nobilax the poodle Zach
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry casperal
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay Brendan
morose and TT thank you for your support
if you want to hear me try and say your
name while this little guy tries to chew
on my earrings well you can check out
the patreon or the support tears that
get you a shout out thanks so much you
are a pain in my butt
[Music]